[Music]
guys shift now available in theaters
everywhere welcome back to the corridor
digital podcast it's episode 132
with
nick laurent sam gorski nico perringer
and of course uh your very own jake
watson thanks for being here everybody i
hope you're having a wonderful day how
are you guys
good i'm excited
and yeah i need to mute
something in the room because i can hear
myself talk
now i can't my brain we don't cut
anything here on the corridor cast
unless the jank is really bad in which
case we usually just cut and start over
we'll see if sam could make it through
this
today's a great day
today's a great day and the reason it's
a great day is because two things got
done
uh two things we're working on for the
last few weeks did we start oh yeah
we're starting yeah and uh
uh uh iron
vfx our vfx aren't an artist yep that's
done yeah finally we watched that that
was
i i was just filled with joy oh it was
very good
[Laughter]
like i'm cracking up like at the top you
know with the hype it's it's fun
but like it's it it like truly gets
amazing when like the the the
competition begins that's where it like
goes into a whole another level
um well yeah thank you uh yeah if you
haven't seen that video it should have
come out when does this come out like a
week from now so
it'll be out it'll be out yeah check it
out if you haven't seen what are you
doing go watch it yeah um yeah some very
good one-liners oh yeah well as well you
guys do everyone knows you know i i spit
out a ton of them i i let you guys just
edit it edit out the bad ones
it's the diamonds on the or it's in
pyramids on the menu right
yeah
dude the cooking show analogy works so
well or competition stuff yeah yeah we
um
we
wanted to shoot that video because we
were like what's a quick one day idea
for a quick video it was a great quick
shoot and then the edit just took a long
time because it's all edited it's like
all it's like the art is the edit 500
percent editing yeah you got absolutely
like
blindsided by this uh edit here
well it's yeah it's the anime vibe you
know it's
i keep calling it i guess yeah it's an
anime vibe because the edit is like
super dramatic yeah it's all the cuts
it's all the footage it's all that stuff
i can
i can see why it took so
so long to
i could have done rap but i literally
could have kept adding stingers and
zings and flame transitions i could have
gone for two more days and it still
would have been
probably the same honestly i know you
just need like some hot keys for like
yeah insert flame trend like we need to
build them into premieres like actually
have it like system at this there's no
way that it's a reality tv show like 14
of these episodes or whatever crazy
amount they do they're like okay let me
locate this one zinger and they go to
their folder like they have to have you
just have a giant sound board usb sound
it's there's like a hundred buttons on
it and they press it and it drops in as
like a
sound effect or like or anything a
symbol roll or like a gong they have a
gong
yeah
that's what you guys need you guys each
need like a 100 key loop deck
with just
pre-programmed sound and effects
transitions we
could probably benefit from that
honestly because i find myself using the
same like 20 sounds uh mostly so you
just need a button that does the work
yes oh well speaking of that speaking up
yeah so that's done
the influencer's done
i was just i literally was talking with
um rodrigo right before this because
he's helping get him uploaded yeah and
and uh i was like oh man i should kind
of like sift through these and take out
some of the bland ones and then i'm like
this is the problem which is like i'm
trying to like over curate it now
where it's okay so
let me pull up this episode you're
getting farther and farther away from
the button
yeah i don't yeah so the but the point
is is that
right now they're they're they're going
up right now and uh i'm just saying
screw this like
one month ago sam
one month ago we had the conversation on
the podcast about how
we should
actually it's time to make this a
reality yeah
okay
and in one month we've got it's gone
from podcast ideas
to fruition yes
a month well spent
i'd say
what's yeah what's the name of the
account can i can i go on instagram it's
not live
it's live at the time of this podcast
release but like we can't watch it in a
second but listeners who are eager to
see an ai driven tick-tock we can tell
the truth yeah yeah we'll just pretend
it's called this is sierra underscore
vega
by the description
i
yeah but um i'm really
i don't know like i you know high hopes
people watch it low hopes
it's a great video
well
yeah i i heard something like you're not
making this correct me if i'm wrong but
you're not making this for for people
you're making this for for them right
yeah maybe we'll see because we're
talking about like maybe how do we get
more subscribers or people to view this
account or like why don't we just like
hire a bot farm
to do it and it's like yes it's
technically breaking the terms of
service but the thing is is that
what if it was
like specifically
for bots
yeah like like content made by bots for
bots like this ai is generating content
for these bots well there's a huge
vacuum like what's wrong with that now
in in the space if i want to use
influencer terms yeah there's no content
for ai yeah bots are only propping up
all this human content
exactly yeah like what
what is out there that's just for bots
you know
only bots.com
yeah
just the meta tag at the right html and
what a lonely existence you know just
scraping through metadata collecting it
in a giant bin somewhere on a google
server i mean there's really more
there's more to life for bots it's so
limiting too because like
they don't bots don't have to constrain
themselves to things that make sense to
humans when they make it exactly
i mean 100
like the more realistic version of that
is just tailoring it to an algorithm you
know but yeah
that's not something a human would do
that's what humans would do yeah
humans try and please algorithms yeah
you're thinking way too human about this
sam yeah yeah
i think sierra is going to reveal to us
what she wants you know oh it's
happening
yeah it's happening so what what does
she want like what have we been finding
from what i've overheard she's kind of a
negative nancy
a little bit
very contemplative
very lost a lot of struggle yeah yeah a
lot of strife and struggle and like
unsure what to do with her life she
might just be trying to be hashtag
relatable yeah
mondays huh you know like
uh don't you just hate it when
yeah there's a lot of that in there i i
do have a question though i've seen the
renders and it looks like sierra
is
like egregiously rich i'll say
i i don't know where she got that house
that's a 20 asset pack sir
you're thinking in human terms jake
she is did she like
did she like get all that money through
her influencing or
uh i think it's in the family i guess
okay you know that's why she's that's
why she's struggling with like what to
do with her life and stuff because she's
family relatives run this like big
youtube channel called uh you know
corridor and quarter digital yeah you
know so it's yeah old money
[Laughter]
oh
man yeah i so i i hope that she finds
her way you know and i don't know what
kind of prompts like you're even giving
it at this point if any
it's minor it's it's one prompt and then
you just let it go and then
um what is it prompt it's it's basically
hey
uh uh it's sierra is like a non-binary
eccentric influencer social media
influencer who posts long-winding
stories of her everyday or its everyday
adventures
and um and then i basically say here's a
suggested
like list of locations available which
is just the locations in the map
uh here's like an array of moods and
here uh you know time of day
uh so and so forth camera angles and
then basically i hit go i give it like
one example prompt to show how to format
it for our scripts and then it just goes
and uh that's basically it
so it really is like
sierra is doing most of the thinking
here yeah exactly there's like zero
backstory it's just like here's this raw
ai it's like an ai's like all right
who's like a eccentric vapid influencer
like what does that sound like all right
here we go and it just starts generating
stuff
but the fun thing is like you know when
we watch it we can then take a
post that we find interesting you know
like it's like if there's something that
us as viewers want to know more about
it's easy then to take that and recycle
that back into the prompt and then
suddenly you start to see more posts
about that topic
um okay so
yeah uh so so that's the basic that's
the way to make it continuous and there
are some storylines that have
been generated through that process
so you got to get like the bot farms to
comment a bunch of stuff and then work
into the
into your net of you know parts that are
feeding into your ai
it's scanning through the bots comments
averaging out what the most hot topics
are and then feedbacking those into the
next content so you truly get that's a
good idea
that that is
a and like also have it scan for like
you know top hashtags and stuff like
that
relevant i'd have to like
manually do that but yeah the one
oversight was we forgot to have like a
like description text for the post
or like hashtags or like all that other
junk you need for posts or whatever
so right now it's literally just talking
it's closer to like a vlog right now
than an actual social media that is the
most sam thing you've ever said
like
because we had this issue with youtube
descriptions for the longest time too
where we're like sam you got to put
stuff in the description and you're like
no why why would i people are there to
watch the video why why does it matter
what's in the description
[Laughter]
probably just yeah i mean this was like
years ago but
but yeah but yeah
yeah 10 years ago
we can improve that we can improve that
easy
okay well good yeah i'm excited man i'm
excited to see what sort of patterns
start forming and like you know what
this
influencer is really all about you know
besides just whining about taking naps
it's all in your head that's that's
that's
all the interesting stuff is the
perceived narrative
you know it's like you know it's it's
it's the same thing as i how do i say it
it's like it's like looking at clouds
you know it's a random shape and you're
like it's a
sea horse
you know it's like that's that that's
the same effect that's happening here
you look at it you're like wow this is
happening this is the story and it's
like nope
but man but it feels like a story
it's that weird thing well man i see i i
think
i do you guys when you guys google stuff
do you kind of ever like do you just
type a question generally speaking or
like almost phrase things as a question
sometimes i'm generally like i'm the
laziest googler by the way ever like
yeah i'll type the first two letters and
i'll try that and then i'll see if it
works
and he's like dude you're the lady
because he's like look up to me he's
like look up satisfying renders
challenge because you're trying to
reference something for an edit and i'd
type in s-a-t
into our crew search
and it didn't work so anyway sorry good
question a little bit sidetracked like
for example so last night my cat got in
a fight with another cat she's ah corey
snuck out we had the back door open a
little bit we didn't know it and she
snuck out at night and i hear a bunch of
yelling and i go out to see what what
all the ruckus is and it turns out it's
my cat getting in a fight with another
cat so i'd break it up
you know um
but you know corey got her back like
chomped oh bit up a little bit she's not
a big cat she's a big cat she's got she
thinks she's a big cat
um yeah she's got a big heart um
so anyways you know she's bit up and
she's you know
tail between your legs kind of like
really like
you know
i guess muted it would be a term
to use to describe her energy when she
came back inside after the fight so of
course you know hop over to google like
my cat got bit by another cat what
should i do
and i literally type in you know cat bit
by other cat treatment options or you
know whatever you know it's like you
kind of just type almost a phrase
and then google pops up with they're
like you know here's like the the
questions that people ask and you click
it it kind of takes you like a relevant
section of an article
it's like you're like i wasn't bit by
another cat what should i do you know so
i click on that question somebody you
know okay here's an article explains it
i start browsing sorry like man it just
kind of repeats itself like in different
ways
but like never quite actually gives
information
and like is this a freaking ai article
and like you know you scroll around and
yeah sure enough like here's the top 10
ways your uh pet might respond to being
attacked they might not eat they might
be lethargic you should only go to see a
vet so how should i respond if my cat is
bitten by another cat well your first
option is to make sure your cat's not
too injured and definitely go see a vet
and like everything is like a
combination of that that just says go
see a vet it's like jeez thanks for
wasting my freaking time
but this is like happening so often now
like any time i type in any kind of
semi-question thing and then google
tries to do like the hey we found that
question being asked thing people have
like fully farmed out like ai stuff to
write these articles with fake questions
to like trigger these google things and
it's like it is making the web unusable
like it's not necessarily these ai
articles it's google it's the way google
structured like their search results and
how they like do hits that's just made
the internet in general like
everything's temporary it all matters
like what's most up to date it's all
lists and like top tens and like
bold pointed breakdowns of different
things with no actual information from
human beings so the only thing i find
useful are actual discussion answers
from forums and from reddit and even
reddit is like oh gosh
take it with a grain of salt a bunch of
people who pretend they know what
they're talking about you know
but it's just like oh man what happened
to like getting my information you know
and of course google like you used to
have this thing that explicitly let you
search discussion things like forums and
stuff like that but i think they removed
it because it got too easy to like
pirate software and movies and tv shows
when you did that because heavens forbid
you link people to other real people
they might do things you don't like you
know you can't control them
it's a victim of its own success niko
yeah it's tough it's yeah
and uh you know i mean
they need like a a filter that like
judges how much humanism yeah it was
like actually in something
this article was written oh don't worry
that's coming this article was written
65 by humans oh man oh no dude
articles not from concentrate i just
need computers not to repeat the same
thing five times in a row different
phrasing
yeah man yeah
yeah i don't know i i like
cats and dogs are pretty resilient
that's i'll tell you that much as a
fellow human
who can answer a human question i will i
will say dogs and cats are pretty
resilient
uh you know like
they get in fights and they have pretty
things that would not be easily
fixable by the body on human beings a
lot of times cats and dogs will be
totally fine
yeah i just don't want the the blood and
pus to be a thing for the next month
like it was the last time she got into
flight well how many uh very well could
be have you talked to her vet about how
many lives she has left
uh yeah you know that's a good question
she's probably down to like six oh [ __ ]
yeah you might want to go see a turret
card reader about that one
card
yeah like paris isn't that
terrible you know a turret reader you
know what i'm talking about
they added an extra t on there to trick
people
a tarot card whatever you know what you
don't know what i'm talking about
[Laughter]
like a tear it on the end of the stick
they'll help you out they'll tell you
how many lives she has left sam you've
said all right twice like you are about
to broach a really important subject all
right bring it up sam
no no no i'm not
you're like all right all right
uh you know i'm over here
uh uh
listening to you guys complaining about
ai again
we do that a lot on this podcast i know
i'm trying to i'm trying to change that
what's better ai that gives you accurate
information but it's just hidden in a
bunch of bs or reddit which gives you
a lot of
probably both yeah i'd much rather watch
people problem solve it and not come to
a conclusion in the in a thread you know
what i'm saying like yeah because even
still then you learn a bunch of other
things it's like here's a bunch of other
solutions and you're like oh sweet dude
everyone save that for later everyone's
opinions on reddit are so dang well
presented though i think freddie freddie
said it best he was i think it was
freddy
it might have been unique but he was
like reddit's like it's like the rap
battle of the world right like
everyone's just like trying to just like
put down their fedora like in the most
elegant way possible
like yeah i realized like i mean this
weird like the upvote down vote thing
has like affected like you know group
think on that website and i've really
realized it's it's a narrative website
right it's not about facts it's not
about news it's not about stories it's
about it's about the narratives you
upload the narratives you want you
download the narratives you don't want
and you all just live in the pretend
reality that you know your words have
described on the forum
it's separate from real life you know
yeah so
yeah it's tough it's too bad like it's
not a yeah
slightly
whatever i'm dumping on reddit here but
whatever i mean hey i go to the website
all the time too but like see what
there's not like a slightly more mature
and like curated version of reddit i
guess or like something that just has a
little more emphasis on like
i don't know i don't know how you do it
no you don't i think the problem is that
there's not a slightly more mature and
curated version of humanity you're right
i think that's that's the problem
yeah you're right yep
do you think this is going to do the new
york times or something
do you think that is going to have uh
going to have arguments when we make the
first ai 4 ai probably definitely argue
all the time i mean dude
man
you know i wonder how much of reddit is
just ai bots do another thing i'm sure
it's a good chunk of it i'm i'm almost
certain that like
half the channels that like consistently
get posted on like big subreddits are
just bot farmed like
like why back in the day when like
binging with babish first came out i
kind of feel like this is wild
accusations all right so guess what guys
this probably isn't true but i'm gonna
say it anyways
it was always upvoted to the top of
videos and like why is a cooking show
hitting the top of videos every time
like i don't see a huge crowd here that
loves it like it's they're good videos
but like they're just cooking videos
right like they're well presented
and i kind of feel like he was playing
the reddit game and like you know
getting those videos upvoted into the
top of the videos page and that's how he
built his following at first year and i
see the same thing happening on the gif
recipes like there's another guy that's
like these recipes are always hitting
the front page anytime they go up there
i'm like ah it feels
feels iffy to me like who captain
disillusion's like the only guy who
constantly gets reddit from like organic
upvotes you know because they just
everywhere should i google top 10
reasons why reddit is bot farmed and see
what happens
i mean why don't we ask him the bots
aren't gonna out themselves jake
the guys from blade runner you know it's
like they pretend to be human you have
to do like a really like deep intense
scan process
i might dig up something here i might
catch one of them one day
i mean casual googling sam have you uh
we were talking about bots for your ai
influencer have you looked into it like
i haven't looked into it no because it's
just gonna get stuff banned man how do
you get an army of robots do you have to
go to like the the star wars
just go to the dark web
of course i would just maybe openly on
twitter be like how do i who knows how
to get boss
[Laughter]
hey i'm gonna be launching this freaking
ai thing let's help let's manipulate the
system everybody would be funny hey
everyone share this or everyone
in interact with it that reminds me like
way back in the day like this is
probably like 2013 or something like
that
maybe 2012.
and
uh
there is
so ivy my wife likes to make greeting
cards as a hobby and this one site that
she has her cards for sale on um held
like a contest or is like all right so
you need you know head over to facebook
you have to like our page and then vote
for who you want to win and just they
picked like six finalists and my wife
happened to be one of them and the
winner gets an ipad
so i go on twitter i'm like hey
everybody this is the corridor account
by the way okay everybody my wife has a
chance to win a free ipad if you all
help out just what for i usually
wouldn't do this but i figured why not
tonight you did this
within a couple hours she blows the
competition out of the water with votes
thanks to everybody who supported her
um
and you know that was that
that was that
so the company like they hit they hit us
up or they hit me up like you know
technically she won
but we really don't approve of the way
you did this i'm like what do you mean
why are you even holding a contest you
want people to go to your facebook page
to follow it and then vote and that's
what every single person had to do you
just got like you're doing this for
publicity and you just got thousands of
eyeballs you just got all the publicity
you wanted now you're telling me like
well
that was too much publicity
we don't we don't want your publicity if
you're gonna win
that's funny either way she got the ipad
here's a little ipad air it's worth 200
bucks
i don't know man that's a strange moral
ground to be on
it it is it was such a tiny little right
in the sense of like that they are they
do just want eyeballs and that's exactly
why they're doing that yeah you have to
go to the page you have to like it so
then you can vote in the thing like
you had to go through all those steps
and they want you know i was like share
with you say share with your friends and
family i consider all of our audience my
friends and family wow
that's crazy man i have a lot of friends
so but that's that's that's stretching
it outside of the reasonable person
expectation nico not not everyone can be
like
well my friends and family are however
many people are following us on twitter
well someone's like oh i have a big
family and i'm gonna get them all to do
anything and someone's like that's not
fair
this is far larger than the average
family i'm not catholic that's not fair
yeah this is way bigger than the average
family i only have two siblings and you
have seven
mm-hmm ban them
right right
yeah only only for families with less
than eight children yeah
all right
look the thing is i i i'm never the guy
to like use our corridor account so it's
a different side i'll win a competition
i had to do it once you know i just had
to do it once but that was like
so long ago too yeah
it's 2012.
yeah yeah you're like for you yeah
that's you you got forgiven like two
years ago
it took a long time still
didn't you say something like this when
we were filming son of a dungeon weren't
you like well listen you guys all
decided to kill their steel or whatever
it was we the rest of the party had done
something bad oh yeah
it was like well i just wanted to try it
because everybody else had done it
like killing those people like yeah i
jumped into the frame like hit a guy
with my sword i don't think i even
killed him i just hit him he was like
whoa
no because we were just talking about
like alignments
and
and he goes like i'm good or like you're
and then your jakes are like i'm neutral
and he's like i'm evil and we're like
what
wait you're eve you've been evil this
whole time you've been like the nicest
like
most like the most like caring
character so far
yeah we all had like opposite alignments
to what we thought we had yeah no but
then the other thing too is like yeah
we're talking about like killing people
it's like wait if you're good you're not
just gonna kill like random people and
then he goes like well i did kill that
one guy
just just because you know we were
everyone was killing it
so like i figured you know what why not
just kill like one
man in reno just to watch him die yeah
i thought he was a bad guy
you guys are all fighting them i figured
you had a good reason yeah yeah
evil party
so what other kind of thing
it didn't turn into quite a debate
in the actual filming session it was fun
that was my favorite
the whole time you guys were arguing
about like what
what someone's alignment could and
couldn't do and yeah that was so good
it's funny because uh when when we
before we started this podcast i was
thinking about starting it off with the
question of whether the world is just
chaos in its entirety and uh
you know
what what does that mean you know jake
are you a freaking ai influencer man
this is exactly the same
well that's what i'm saying is ai just
another human attempt to wait are we in
accordance
with some of that chaos
yep dude we're all just we're just eyes
man yeah no ace
that's true guys wow
i'm gonna try my best impression of
sam's ai influencer
um
hey guys let's think about the world i
think about chaos and how everything's
just crazy is it just us or is there a
purpose to it all i don't know i'm
curious to hear your thoughts
music pop music plays cut to dancing
10 reasons why the world is chaos
hey man
a lot deeper for many influencers though
i gotta say i just wonder if this ai bot
will start like trying to fight people i
was just thinking today about cell crypt
how many problems there are in the world
do you think we'll ever solve them what
problem in the world would you like to
solve
you're gonna get a great engagement on
that one you know i really hope that
like it it
this is obviously going to have to be
coincidental or serendipitous but i'm
really hoping that there's a moment
where this thing is posting
and it just
it it just hits
the right tone on a post or something at
the right time where it's like more
right about something than anybody else
i'm just hoping that that happens once
and we're approaching a monkey and
typewriter situation yeah i mean i could
spice it up like i can just say hey
weigh in on this
you know it's like too much power
chris rock what do you think oh that's a
good what do you think
yeah
you know the thing is too like
so sam's you know this is running tpt3
right
so you you're prompting it you're
putting down formats bring down words
and you can just you can do things with
gpt3 like
you can add the words and it's extra
good and then like the gpd3 will like
make an extra good version of your story
or it's like and this story is very
emotional and won many awards and then
it just writes an even better story that
would win awards it's a weird way to
like shape the ai
that you can like put those things in i
know when people were making uh pictures
yeah i generated pictures and they
wanted the pictures like look extra good
they just put unreal engine 5 afterwards
so what picture looks like an unreal
thing a baby would say yeah
engine 5 afterwards you know no it's
really
unreal engine five it gives you like the
temple on mars but it makes it with good
graphics
i mean
it must have just had like a blanket
node for like uh
what it thought that program to give you
well it's just because like you know
there's so many pictures of like cool
cgi like associated with unreal engine
you know it's a look if i say unreal
engine you can see the graphics in your
head
all right you know only if you're a
giant geek maybe like us but yeah still
yeah
it's crazy how like it it just
simplifies everything
all of our human concepts it just turns
into
quick buzzwords what's that it's like
the google search yeah
version of it all where it's like what
are people searching for
and what do they expect them how are
they searching for it do they write
whole questions like nico or two letters
like me
[Laughter]
no it is
[Laughter]
you google like one or two things and it
goes like you're search you're trying to
dig deeper i know you and it knows that
you're gonna like dig deeper on a
subject and it like auto completes
properly have you noticed have you
noticed phones do this when you're
talking about a subject and then you go
to google it on your phone
mm-hmm phone's on list
conspiracy theorists this is this is
just the way that it is like
if you're talking about something and
and then you google it from your phone
yeah just those data points man it's got
these data points and you've so dialed
in and all of a sudden
i don't think i don't know because it'll
it'll be it'll do it with like random
topics
like uh like
everybody has this conspiracy not
everywhere but i've heard the conspiracy
theory that you know your phone's always
listening to you
or like you know i'm just having a
conversation and then i picked up my
phone and had an ad for the thing i was
talking about
but the thing is
that's more or less impossible because
your battery would drain so fast if your
phone was always listening to you no i
understand that that
side of it i understand the actual
hardware logistical limitations of of of
how we apply that i'm just saying this
happens
fairly regularly
and people have done uh different videos
where they've sort of tested this over
time
and they've tried to make sure like the
data set that they use is like clean of
previous influence
and it does tend to there is some
tendency that it shows a pattern where
it's like
specific topics will come up first if
you've spoken about those
in front of the phone no no no no no no
no no no no no
no dude i know i know you're
how much of this
have you thought about prior to this
conversation right i've looked into it
actually i've actually researched this
one
um because
basically you're implying is that your
phone is listening to you
well i don't know what i don't know in
the manner
you know the the the actual manner in
which it's
you know collecting every word and then
sending that through a database or it's
looking for key points that it's heard
before or you know key key key ad points
or things like that i don't know that
but
yeah i mean
i think the big thing that people are
very surprised to learn is just
how good statistical prediction is and
how much data points these companies
have on us
very well
it could be it could be like a
statistical data points run through
you know like a bunch of different sub
sub nodes to like give you a super
accurate prediction of what you're
googling
i'm not saying that's not possible and
i'm not trying to propose conspiracy
theories either like i'm just i'm just
trying to say
what i've seen
the thing that people like get really
surprised about
it's like you know they go to a friend's
house and their friend will start
talking about something and then like
the ads will pop up on their phone but
like i think that gets people by
surprise like when you take
like the data points to different people
you know they're not just looking at
yours they're looking at who's in your
house and who comes to visit and when
they come to visit and they're having
those data points interact they're
comparing that to the same data points
interacting in other places and they go
okay what's the most common outcome of
these data points interacting and it
puts those predictions to you so it's
like it's so complex and deep and
evolving and of course driven by a lot
of ai and machine learning as well and
predictive
that like you end up with these like
whoa how did they know kind of moments
when in reality it's just very very good
math
so i will say like you know people talk
about like the alexa's listening to you
and that's something where you can
actually just you can track the data on
your network and see whether or not it's
sending data back home
and you can sniff that data and see
what's being sent
and in that case like they aren't
sending data unless you say the trigger
word to cause it to start recording
because there's actually a hardwired in
uh piece of i guess like firmware
hardware i don't know in the like your
alexa that turns it on to start
recording that's why you can only give
it a couple certain names you can't just
give it any name it's because it's
hardwired in to only start recording
when it hears one of those five
different sounds of course once it
starts recording then it's fair game
i i so
just
caveat on that
yeah there there is
both on amazon alexa and you know the
other
home assistant ai devices out there
as well as on the
phones yes
trigger words
that's how it that's the basic function
of the technology right
but what's like
what's to say that it's it can't just
also say oh and and also there's these
other trigger words
you know that we don't tell you about
well that's because there's two
different like levels here like
because the all the voice processing
like when you're talking to your phone
or to a lex or to google you know that's
being sent across the network over to
their servers and that's run through an
ai that then parses the words
um
but that first bit when you start
talking to it that doesn't have time to
go to the server and come back so that
has to be hardwired in
um yeah and you can i mean people have
popped them literally popped them open
and gone through the hardware
to you know to see what triggers it and
when it starts recording and how like
the network data changes and you know
which things can trigger it so
i don't think there's like secret words
that could trigger it because then
immediately you have a spike in your
network traffic and you know your ports
open up and stuff starts flowing
so you you would see it happen i guess
if you but it is it is always listening
for trigger words it is
and so is your phone though but but
that's not being sent over network
that's not being recorded i understand i
understand that but it's a local
hardware thing versus a connected
hardware thing
i yes but in order for it to go hey if
you say hey siri
and it it it's like it's trick it's it
is always listening for that word yes
okay so
when i you know
there is there is a little bit of but
that that information doesn't get that
doesn't leave the phone well i mean we
don't know what information they're
actually sending like i just think that
we don't know exactly that's what
they're saying like
packets associated
with that info when it does send yeah i
just wouldn't assume that they're not
that's it's i mean you know it's a big
conspiracy but i'm just going to say
your alexas and your google homes and
your phones they're not just constantly
recording you and saving that and
sending it off no of course they're not
constantly doing that like that would be
a ridiculous waste of data space
for no real batteries i mean you could
see yeah their pants off into oblivion
and be you know set for life like yeah
maybe
yeah okay but you're but but i am saying
the microphones
under under the definition that the
microphones are always listening for
specific trigger devices they are always
listening and there's a very short
removal from that which is we know to be
true which is just oh and also
you know they're listening for these
trigger words too and when they hear
those
they do x y or z
small packets of information pings
across a different you know pings to an
ai server somewhere like that all could
also be happening
and we're just not
you know like queued up to it because
it's not part of the
it's not important really in terms of
like
day-to-day use
consumer use all those things
yeah and you know given given what we
know about like how much information
is stored
you're just saying that they could be
doing it nico says they're not doing it
well i'm just look at look at also look
at like the the data they're trying to
be turned over to the nsa and stuff like
that i mean
look at the amount of data that that
tech companies turn over to like the nsa
and and other
governmental entities like plenty of
data yeah that's there's others we give
them plenty of data like they don't need
to hear us say who jet ski to
no yeah i know we want a jet ski
this dude's like
every time he his thumb like hovers over
this jet ski picture it's like it takes
an extra half second yeah
well you can start with just a basic
point that everybody wants a jet ski
yeah so you hear me with a jet ski ad
just once just to make sure and if
people are googling everything that's
not jet ski related it means they must
not have a jet ski
google's like hey he just watched
a jet ski or there's a video with a jet
ski in it and then he immediately
watched another jet ski video
interesting
yeah it's actually you guys are popping
you guys are positively optimistic about
it which is totally reasonable i'm just
saying like
what you're saying is just as plausible
as what i'm saying like big skidoo would
never
never do it
you're saying you're saying that that's
just a series of good math based on
other data sets and i'm just saying well
it could also be that they're taking
little packets and including that in the
data set that's that's not so crazy to
be like oh yeah that's that's a
conspiracy thing you're telling me if
i'm around my alexa home and i'm talking
about i want prime shipping on a tablet
to read right a book
triggers not listening to that yeah
did you read all the did you read the
whole thing oh you guys are being
for a corporation to
uh illegitimately and without permission
record in your home and send the data
off
sorry one question how is it
illegitimate violation of how is it how
is it legitimate how is it a violation
let's go through the terms of services
these companies have come out and said
they don't do this multiple times like
yeah publicly clearly so you're going to
take them at their word given what you
know
they have done in the past
come on i mean no look look look there's
there's something i'm just gonna say
there's plenty of people far more
motivated than us to get to the bottom
of this and they have already and
we would have known
something has happened by now i just
want to point out you just saying well
they say they don't no so that means
they must not
okay guys guys pretty thin
literally
this is all speculation
until we pull up the terms of service
i've got him in front of me i've got him
in front of him
the reason there's a reason you don't
read them
don't unsubscribe we're gonna stop
talking about this don't subscribe
please please stop watching come on
all right so
we're gonna talk about will smith or
alex troy next no let's just
it doesn't matter look i think the
academy lost a lot of respect and they
didn't escort out the guests who
assaulted their hosts yeah that's that's
that's not yeah that was not appropriate
obviously but obviously yeah but it's
will smith who yeah whatever you want a
movie no that's what i'm saying though
like that's the mentality is it's like
well if this is somebody who's named
then all of a sudden it's okay
it's not okay look it's not okay
yeah
theatrical expertise i have to say his
posture yeah he slapped like an action
scene no no it was a good slap i think
it was it was a gentleman's slap for
sure you think it was a gentleman's slap
if anybody had his block
they would have immediately been sent to
jail
yeah yeah which is that and i i love all
these dumb dumbs on freaking the
internet who are
saying what we're saying except bring it
to the extremes
you know they're like you should have
been arrested he could have
killed
chris rock
and it's like anybody who's eggshells
i've read that from people i personally
know
in real life i've seen people say that
on on the stupid internet the old stupid
old internet
and it is just hilarious that's like oh
my god that style of thinking is just so
dumb yeah
personally i was a little glad to see a
little bit of uh you know
roughness
occur
you want some action in your oscars i i
honestly i appreciate that a little bit
i think people should be a little bit
more used to that kind of activity you
insult somebody especially in the in
that way look maybe make
[Laughter]
violence is not an appropriate response
to words well guess what it turns out
that that's not entirely true niko don't
i agree
i agree that it's not entirely true
and i think that if you walk up to
someone and berate them and they decide
to hit you then that is oh yeah
sometimes a valid response yeah i think
that's right of course of course it's
going to happen like
but no one should be like an appropriate
response to words is violence like that
just blanket should not be no i i agree
what do you mean by should what do you
mean by should
word that violence should not be a
response to yeah here's the thing
mental health health or not you know
what i'm saying
[Laughter]
if you've gone through health or not
people like to argue all this dumb
[ __ ] it's like oh no no mental
health is health that is like such such
an integral part of your being your
mental health should be just as
important as your physical health and
okay well you go take that argument
which does have a lot of validity and so
now someone use words against you oh
guess what they're doing they're harming
your mental health
how do you do that well what do you if
you don't have like a
even more crazy comeback to zing them
with
a slap will do you
know
i'm just saying like come on that's how
people work this is how people work it's
literally our constitution that being
said in this speech like we're going to
get slapped for saying this whole thing
has just been so much better if he walks
up and slaps them and then they're like
okay sir come on you have to get out of
here and then that's the end of that and
then everyone's like cool he deserved
the slapped and then he got he left and
there's consequences there's
consequences perfect bravo there we go
it's fair on all sides now
no it's anyways so stupid the whole
oscars is theater and like the act that
we've
we've
made a tradition of a comedian razzing
people in the audience is oh yeah it's a
planned theatrical event i'm surprised
the golden globes haven't turned into a
freaking melee yeah people are wearing
kevlar like ricky gervais is just like
he's like please dear god do not talk
about me
and he's like hey he has like security
guards now yeah i know
yeah i'm just so i don't know man
like oh sorry your ego is so
damaged i mean clearly will smith's like
suffering well i will say this for
anybody that has sympathy for will smith
cool because people do deserve second
chances you don't put like when somebody
you know gets convicted of a crime the
idea is not just put them away forever
and never see them again the idea is to
rehabilitate them back into society
you know so it's like it's like sir you
can just don't slap this time and be
like okay i have to say
and you know like i do wish that was a
little bit more in people's
approaches to things it's like
like
people need to have consequences you do
need to have punishments but it is with
the goal of making that person back into
a better person you know and people
forget about that the vindictiveness can
take over and then just like yeah put
them away forever
it's like well i mean yeah sure
obviously there's some people who are
broken beyond repair and there's some
people who are evil beyond all else you
know and there's nothing you can do
about that but obviously the vast
majority of people
you know
you can you can work on rehabbing as
your main goal but regardless i
personally think a slap is is is
something you can't get charged for
i don't think that's not it wasn't
blatantly open-handed so i'm just saying
you know i'm just saying walking up and
slapping someone is an assault
no question i guess
assault i know but that's like what i
was like really
come on yeah is that within the
acceptable terms of like interaction
strike another person
you they can call the cops and you can
go but what's the strike yeah but nico
you are you saw this yeah
well what if that hurt it didn't you're
by definition
but how do i know how do you prove what
you felt well look i mean
you could murder someone with a dish
sponge and it would still be murder you
wouldn't get any street cred in the
cafeteria jail for it you know like the
big guy would yeah
if i throw a sponge at someone is that
so what happened legally let's just talk
about this this actual incident all
right uh finally some sense first first
of all what happened legally
is the slap
assault yes it is assault is the you
know uh physical or perceived physical
uh
harm that's coming at you
right um by the way do is it this
courage for lawyers to say the words you
know when talking about
things okay what
you know
you know because we don't
okay no no okay you know my client
committed
you know
okay stop it
look let's i want to do
so was that assault yeah it was it was
it was a it was a battery mm-hmm is it
a subset of assault or is not assault is
assault is anything that would
create a perceived infliction of
physical harm or unwanted personal
contact even if there wasn't actual
contact so
spending on somebody would be assaulting
just just walking over to someone
angrily well spitting on somebody
could be yeah it's probably it's
definitely assault it could be battery
probably not
i don't know i don't know that might be
a jurisdictional thing but battery is
when it goes from perceived words or
action
that doesn't actually touch to then
actually contact interest and then that
becomes battery
um so so it's salt and bat it's classic
assault and battery right but what you
also have to consider is yeah is it a
sultan battery yes now was it justified
right this doesn't because it doesn't
just cut one way like if if if you if
you say did you
murder somebody okay did you did you
intentionally take the life of another
person being of another person
right
with with wonton desire to take that
person's life the next question then
becomes well yes did you commit murder
okay yes but did were you justified in
the in the murder was somebody trying to
murder you did something else happen to
you was there some other thing would
somebody put a gun to your head like
what are there other circumstances that
might be mitigating to the murder itself
you can do the same thing with assault
and battery you can say was it assault
and battery yes were there mitigating
circumstances also yes
you know like if if if you walk up to
somebody on the street
you don't know them and you just start
insulting them
right
now not only is that assault
if you're it depending on how close you
are and the particulars of your action
but also
if that person strikes you because they
don't they're you're in their face they
don't know what's happening you're
you're insulting them you know and and
they're like like
and that's not
they're not gonna
you're not gonna get away with saying oh
well now i'm gonna prosecute them for
battery
because your actions provoked the
battery
and that would be considered totally
okay so we're talking about a slightly
minor version of this here now now you
have to consider oh well the fact that
public figure
awards show
expectation of no expectation of privacy
both like being filmed and people
insulting you like from a comfort of
comedic purposes like that's considered
totally fair game at in an environment
like that so you do that has to be
considered and then you have to and then
and then it's like well it wasn't
insulting me it was insulting my wife
and da da da and it's like well now man
maybe you took it too far there buddy
you know
but again you have to consider both of
those things as being part taking in
that thing and and then you can come to
like an accurate if he was to be
actually prosecuted then you could come
to an accurate assessment of like what
the punishment would be it'd be most
likely yeah you're guilty of assault but
here's a very light sentence slap on the
wrist fine type of thing this is for
like somebody who's
again
not going to be seen as will smith you
know
but again this is this is the
fundamental problem in the sense that we
apply different rules
to somebody like that versus the rules
that we apply to with just an individual
and even though that's not the way that
things are supposed to be set up
yeah so i would say chris rock is
definitely a pro and he handled that
so well
so much better than
anybody else could have probably
just like smooth like sailed right
through
got his bearing
didn't dig in
even if you listen like you can see him
like he's like oh yeah it was just a
joke what i could have and he like he
starts like he just barely starts like
another
really oh wow
he stops himself he's like
all right anyways on to our next thing
it's funny yeah well i guess it does
kind of come like well it validates my
point which is slaps being a valid
course of action
in a lot of situations
because i mean i'm not talking about
slapping a ram i didn't say that that
doesn't mean that slapping is just
somehow justified in every circumstance
so basically no i'm just saying like
i'm i'm only talking about in a
situation where i want to slap someone
not not unjustly
i'm so i'm i i'm just saying hey yo
someone comes up and tease you oh
and you're like
slap
that does it okay it's so it's so
circumstantial though sam and i was like
yeah
someone's like don't park in my parking
spot
that yeah
no no no don't park and then they
probably said something else that
warranted yeah they have to insult your
mother first yes they say you are stupid
and smell bad and i'm like
two strikes are out i was like all right
well
i don't know man it was just
you know it was one of the most
entertaining things to happen on
television for a long time so i guess
thanks will smith so we got that going
for us
and by the time this podcast comes out
it's gonna be such old news
talking about this old news for like 20
minutes dude everyone memed on it so
hard for 24 hours and that was it yeah
that's how we process things as a
society now we just mean it all of our
all of our traumas and that's how we
get over them
i don't know i just feel bad for any
comedian now who has to get up and
insult people that's true because just
like
who who was the uh the roman
like commander that marched his troops
was it was it caesar that marches troops
into in the room yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
and it was like it was like the holy
rules that you never
walk your troops into the city and he
used to do this person to break it and
then of course once he does it everybody
starts breaking
yeah is that now what's happened with uh
you know hecklers and comedians on stage
now that will smith broke the rule
everything yeah whatever becomes like
hockey rules caesar broke multiple rules
though so
yeah
but yeah no i think there's a point
hockey rules that's a really interesting
concept like the concept of precedent
and like the inability of people to
understand that
just because someone does something
doesn't mean now it's suddenly okay to
do it yeah it's that is kind of
interesting well clearly it's okay to do
it like all you have to do is post an
apology on his instagram
he did i mean that's not that bad
it wasn't being verbal yeah but
screenshotting the amount of people
reading the apology versus you know yeah
seeing yeah that's kind of weird i mean
i hope more comedians don't get slapped
but you know whatever it's already like
they're already dealing with so much
other crap
i mean maybe that's like where comedy is
going it's more of like a fight kind of
thing it's slapstick that's what we're
going back to
touchline slapstick
will like they'll build little forts
before the stage you know before the
show opens right yeah and it'll be like
can you get past my trip wires i'm gonna
keep roasting you
do you try and hit me
for a comment
it's
there is a form of this style of comedy
though that goes back to like the middle
ages and and is also manifested in like
county fairs when people like are in the
dunk tanks
you know oh dude they do that at the ren
fair and they they roast you at the red
fair you walk up and then they're like
you you look like [ __ ]
your costume sucks
yeah
and they don't know but they're in the
middle people
they used to put people in the uh what
are those called the lock the locks
where you lock your head and arms the
stocks yeah and people used to sit in
there and assault and insult people and
you could like you know
[Music]
yeah you could buy all that that was the
punishment it was you get to be insulted
by the whole town and
right you're at their mercy for an hour
but part of it but part of the game
is like you can insult back
dude you know just lord of the stalks
like you're just making people
cry
challenge accepted
[Laughter]
man yeah it's hard to make jokes when
you have tomatoes hitting your face
though so yeah i don't know man you
gotta you really gotta you really gotta
be tenacious to do it but i'm sure
people have done it
yeah it's it's really interesting we
should explore this
let's go and try it
let's go and try it in a public park
hey you
you're just in a box fort that's like 20
feet
i dare you
oh man well shift wasn't uh nominated
this year so no it's not it's not gonna
watch it's coming it's gonna it's gonna
catch yeah
we'll we'll put out shift two
and we'll just keep remaking it until
until it catches what's the shift
oh it's the movie with tom cruise where
he loses a hundred pounds yeah yeah he
plays a mechanic he needs to reconnect
with him
it's an indie finance piece um by
somebody who has a parent who is an
actor oh we should get apple to fund it
yeah and then we got we got our buddies
together they know how to please work
the oscars
yeah okay and um we got tom cruise
tom cruise is actually the lead uh he's
a mechanic who has a struggling marriage
and is uh on the rocks with his daughter
his his teenage daughter
and uh he lost 90 pounds for the roll
that's the that's the point
that everyone talks about is yes sir
yeah he weighs like it's like 70
[Laughter]
it all ends with the finale of his him
walking away his daughter walking away
from him saying you can't tell me how to
live my life
and it ends
yeah his job as a mechanic but also his
shift on his life respectively it's
basically just like calling so it's kind
of like calling a movie like arc
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
totally there's like two more layers to
it too that you have to watch the film
yeah yeah last time we actually asked
for everyone who sought to leave reviews
in the comments so hopefully we see some
good reviews in the comments of this
video yeah we'll send those screeners
yeah
um yeah that was the first movie i
actually worked on so i'm very proud of
it um yeah it's pretty cool tom cruise
is just a little i don't know if we were
saltier in this podcast or in that
podcast
oh man yeah
what were you guys salty about
i don't know you're salty about oscar
nominees we're talking about oscar
nomins and stuff i was getting on
manchester by this we're just saying
and people got angry at us oh [ __ ] i
said we wouldn't do that anymore you
said it
i missed the manchester by the sea dunk
fest
you said the fighting words man oh i'm
just yeah i mean it stemmed mostly for
me being angry that last duel got no
oscar nominations despite being the best
movie of last year
i mean next to spider-man
yeah spider-man deserve the best picture
let's be real yeah come on i mean it was
pretty cool there's three spider-mans
like next year i guess
next year they'll try out four they will
tell you where else are you
guys friday
how many spider-mans are in that one
movie someone the director spoiled it or
something on twitter venom's in it or
something like that oh [ __ ] sorry
everybody it's okay
i haven't seen it yet i'm just guessing
[Laughter]
exactly what i'm talking about this is
what happened
but it's also how he came up with shift
anyways he does act like he's watching
himself on the monitor act like there's
certain actions described that way
before that's exactly
but you know there's some actors who you
can't get them out of that like there's
some actors who are just so natural but
then there's actors who are always
watching themselves and they're just
imagining how this is gonna look yeah
right you can't act if you're doing that
no if you're just like oh i'm gonna look
sick when i do this and then you're
describing my acting method bro
i gotta work on it
well
you're not pulling it off
you're pretty good oh thank you
no but honestly that's what jared leto
yeah to sum it all up to sum up the dunk
here we could
so one more thing to end this podcast on
not related to the freaking oscars or
jared leto or something okay
good
so we did uh we did a video with uh an
ai thing where our voice is called that
i think was called altered.ai and
basically
you can speak and then just like how a
deep fake can put another person's face
on your face this basically puts another
voice in your voice so it's the same
words the same cadence but you can take
a different voice model and put on your
voice there's another company that does
this called reese feature it's very
similar technology to altar.ai and reese
features the ones that did the uh the
voice
for luke skywalker um in mandalorian
boba fett
um and i actually reached out to them as
we were doing this ai stuff like a few
weeks ago to talk to them about you know
the idea of using their software
and
what i didn't know is they're based in
ukraine
uh yeah you know straight up like having
a you know
morning video call they're like yeah
we're in the western part of the country
and it's just like wow and like
something that feels so much closer like
when you're when you're doing that
but
they're doing something kind of
interesting uh you know because there's
like we get all these emails from people
saying like you should deep fake putin
into like telling the troops to retreat
or something like that which is just
it's weird to get those those emails but
it's like well how can you use machine
learning like for some of this like you
know for a good cause kind of thing so
reese feature is actually doing
something kind of interesting and
anybody listening to this podcast
happens to have like a decent sized
following and you're interested in
participating
in this maybe leave a comment down below
or hit me up and i'll figure out a way
to get in touch with you um but
basically what they're doing is
they're asking like influencers and
celebrities and stuff if they're
interested in recording like a message
of support for the ukrainian people
and then they take that person's voice
and they train it so they can have that
person speak ukrainian with their own
voice
which is crazy so like you know you can
basically say like you know you guys you
know
keep it up i know time's tough you have
our support you know whatever it's like
you can say whatever you want it's like
it's a message for the people right
and then they'll train your voice and
then they will basically puppet your
voice by speaking ukrainian then have it
be in your voice tone so it's now you
can make a video for you know the
ukrainian people but you're speaking
their language but it's still your voice
it's it's really cool it's a really
interesting thing that they're doing
yeah and if anybody listening this
podcast is interested in participating
in that assuming
sorry not to just rule everybody out but
it takes time for them to make these
models so if you have a following and
you're interested in this reach out to
me leave a comment whatever i'll find
you
we're like so close to having actual
devices where you just talk into it i
know it says any language in your voice
yeah well they exist they just don't
mimic your actual voice yeah yeah yeah
yeah and now we're getting to where it
can mimic your voice like a magic yeah
you buy one and then you spend like it's
like the setup is like 20 minutes to
just record some audio so we can
replicate your voice and it's just like
then you're good yeah it's crazy go for
it yeah that'll be incredibly useful for
um
well it won't even be dubbing dubbing's
the wrong word dubbing is the verb now
for it but dubbing
uh our videos
yeah
yeah
yeah and they can add a little like
yeah it's yeah sorry i'm just my brain's
like super excited because i just want
to travel the world and speak uh speak
all the languages now that would be cool
and you have a little earpiece that's
yeah you have a little speaker in your
mouth so you just open your mouth
[Laughter]
excuse me one second
all right
i gotta wrap i gotta wrap this up y'all
all right it's been good that's it all
right so what did we learn we learned no
hitting just because somebody made a
maybe a distasteful joke or a joke you
thought was distasteful don't don't be
hitting children okay because it's
really personal nice
and then still you might get in trouble
still so just be advised just remember
yeah just remember you might get in
trouble yeah
and uh you know so it's a risk it's
taken a risk um second thing oh and also
if you're gonna insult somebody deeply
you're taking a risk too yeah
regardless of what shouldn't happen
doesn't mean it won't happen you don't
say it's like
having it right away it's like
pedestrians do have the right of way
cars are still heavier
right
don't uh yeah don't don't think that
just because somebody's not supposed to
hit you that they won't
um
and then uh what else did we learn about
ai influencers sam we learned that uh
is gonna be live underscore vega yeah go
check it out
check it out
check it out
yeah go check it out
and uh oh yeah and also if you um
want to do the
voice translation thing like nika was
talking about
um you can have a comment or shoot me an
email or yeah that would be like
instagram or something i don't know yeah
we'll figure it out yeah okay yeah do it
and nick is already working on the
script for shift two yeah shift oh yeah
an iron artist or iron chef vfx iron
chef check out vfx we haven't seen it
that's so good it's so good it's so good
you're live right now yeah let us know
if you want us to do more of those
videos yeah because i think we got a
format yeah
cool all right
thanks for watching all right everybody
hot ejection thanks for watching
everybody
it's been good
it's been a good time
all righty
[Music]